getting my herbst appliance put back in
tada
hello my name is yvonne i'm fun 21 and
i'm elsewhere based military wife in
south dakota
[Music]
one of the most asked questions i get is
how long i have the herbs appliances my
journey began may 10 so roughly around
eight months i've had it
now why why did i get the herbs
appliances so i had horrible tmj
teeth crowding and an overbite without
reduction
[Music]
my general experience having her plans
has seriously been life-changing at the
beginning of my journey i cannot open my
mouth
and now i can i've seen all my tick
tocks
[Music]
something awesome while having hearts of
friends has been able to share my story
with other people encourage other people
to get anything concerning checked out
and just
showing off my plans on the other hand
something sucky about it is that most of
the time when i'm eating i'm focusing on
picking the food out more than actually
eating the four
[Music]
best water pick
ew water seaweed
brush brush brush
brush the metal
[Music]
baby toothbrush
[Music]
brush between metal
one of the worst parts is having swords
on my lips i literally have one right
now and honestly i have one most of the
time
[Music]
after
my advice for our viewers would be to
brush your metal use mouth guards to
prevent
sores and please eat soft foods
[Music]
[Music]
you